[Music]
so the u.s
senate votes proceed with the second
vote has voted to proceed with the
second impeachment trial of donald trump
rejecting the defense argument that it's
unconstitutional to try
a former president let's start with alan
fisher on capitol hill where he tells us
what to expect
in the coming days in a place that has
seen a lot of it
this truly was a historic day the second
impeachment trial
of donald trump before the senate can
even begin to question whether or not he
was guilty of high crimes and
misdemeanors
whether he sent a crowd towards capitol
hill
for a violent insurrection aimed at
overturning the results of a democratic
election
there's the question of whether or not
it was constitutional to put him on
trial
the democrats said absolutely he had to
be held responsible for what he did
in those final days in office his
defense team argued
that he's no longer in office and so
it's too late
our case is based on cold
hard facts people died that day
officers ended up with head damage and
brain damage
people's eyes were gouged
an officer had a heart attack an officer
lost three fingers
that day
two officers have taken their own lives
senators this cannot
be our future
this cannot be the future of america
we cannot have presidents inciting and
mobilizing mob violence against
our government and our institutions
because they refuse to accept the will
of the people under the constitution of
the united states
was also an unforgivable betrayal of the
oath of office of president trump the
oath he swore
an oath that he sullied and dishonored
to advance his own personal interests
donald trump's defence team said that
what happened on capitol hill on january
the 6th was horrendous
but also putting him on trial was
unconstitutional
this they argued was simply the
democrats carrying out
a partisan political hit job on a man
they didn't want to see run for office
again
forgetting that 10 republicans had also
voted
for the impeachment of donald trump you
will not hear any member of the team
representing former president trump
say anything but in the strongest
possible way
denounce the violence of the
rioters and those that breached the
capitol the very citadel
of our democracy we can't possibly be
suggesting
that we punish people for political
speech in this country
with this trial you will open up new and
bigger wounds across the nation
for a great many americans see this
process for exactly what it is
a chance by a group of partisan
politicians
seeking to eliminate donald trump from
the american political scene
the senate has now voted to push ahead
with the hearing it will begin
on wednesday one republican senator was
asked why he voted
to make sure that the hearing would go
ahead he said that the house team
led by jamie raskin was much more
focused and answered the questions
that were in front of them whereas
donald trump's team
was much more unfocused almost as if
they were trying to avoid
the central question of whether or not
he was responsible
for the violence that was seen here on
capitol hill
what is clear is that donald trump's
team will have to be a lot more focused
as they move in
to the important part of the impeachment
proceedings will donald trump be
convicted
it's still a long shot but his legal
team will have to perform
much better than they did on day one